[Musique]
on va regarder le sud là où bat ivan
seria mon nouvel hymne à vite
en vérité les chansons faites y un
appartement à vendre des genres masculin
masculin reste une garçonnière
c'est à quel étage ton 9e et à combien
est à 8 8
alors ces deals habitait au neuvième
jour d'être dérangé segal forcer la
porte de gauche mais avant vous sonné à
la porte de phase iia deux entraînements
il récuse la porte à gauche
alors quoi vous dis que je sonne à la
porte de fass ouvrir voilà vous savez je
vous aurez vous entrez dans les cibles
devant la salle de bain y'a pas de
vestibule de l'échanger contre quoi
une salle de bains elle est grande cette
salle de bain le mètre sur 1 sur un
couac sur un tapis de sol et après la
salle de bain alors le gym d'ars le
gymnase 5 mais pas de stades dont
j'attendais une subvention j'ai pas eu
la pudeur
qu'est ce que vous faites dans ce
gymnase de gymnastique non c il est
grand père m sur deux ans mature
d'autres engine à sa cartouche au sud
quand c'est possible mais quelle belle
point dur des dons c'est au plafond un
maître un maître que ce qu'on veut bien
faire d'un gymnase d'un mètre de haut
les abdominaux
là c'est vrai j'ai pas français mais
comment se fait-il que ce soit si bart
plafond bas parce que si vous avez le
living-room way se livrent aux mesures à
mettre sur deux je suppute un nom
lamouri but est de travers ce livre ils
ont besoin et évidemment 15 mètres sur
18 ha bah voilà enfin une caisse
confortable on peut recevoir des amis
est impossible pourquoi elle est
encombrée encombré de coiffes de caisse
de quête semée de pièges au fait de
l'exportation d'exportation de quoi te
questionnes évoqué ces petites caisses
histoire des pizzas les moyennes qui ne
fait pas la grosse caisse format mono ou
ça au concert par de l'eau ah oui en
somme il joue de la grosse caisse à pas
de loup du samu en vie alors à gauche
dans le fond de vidéo vous avez une
porte qui donne sur le fils a pas ce
qu'est un office à vous tous les
dimanches et à droite une porte qui
donne sur la rue sur la rue sur la rue
du 9 yens du 9e a bâti dans ça fait une
grande marche assez fait grincer ticket
donne sur la bien avant elle donne accès
à la cuisine mais chez vendu la cuisine
acquis à des étrangers
l'idée au repos tellement vous êtes bien
plus étrange et adore la cuisine
française
et où manger vous sur une petite caisse
et où dormez-vous dans une grande pièce
qu'est ce que c'est drôle
1 non rien du gange absolument me
débarrasser de ceux les lignes on
m'aimait caisse mais votre exportations
gestion mais j'en ai par dessus la tête
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
maintenant de l'importation de
l'importation de coiffe de planche pour
quoi faire
les caisses oui eh ben mon vieux votre
immigrent m'intéresse avec us en caisse
avec les caisses ce sont les caisses qui
m'intéresse à vous faites aussi dans la
caisse non moi je suis dans le coin coin
donc oui dans quel coin n'importe quel
coin n'importe quel coin la croatie aux
états donc quelle sorte de coin mais
tous les coins le fou est en général
quels fruits le coib dans le point mais
non enfin le coin le fruit le coin coin
alors quoi quoi oui les klaxons mais non
le coin les gars c'est que cette fois
devancé par exemple ce moment je
travaille avec la sncf oui je le
revendique un couloir adéquat fenêtre le
coin voilà tchèques ont pris le coin et
vitalic avec la sncf
non non non je fais tous les coins 7
pour les roquois n'ont jamais de copies
qu'est ce que vous faites comme
autrefois avec au bout de quoi je fais
le coin de rue la cuisine les 80 pour
les enfants c'est pas le petit coin non
trop de concurrence
cette interdiction ce moment sont hors
de prix oui l otan vous êtes notre de
père en fils ça vous plaît tu nord mes
parents m'ont forcée qu'auriez vous aimé
faire j'aurais voulu être l'amant
brigitte bardot rares héros n'ont pas
voulu non c'est elle on va dédommager
une affaire vous proposez vous explique
on lui demande mais 15 ou 20 ans mais
coin quelconque des couennes n'est qu'à
6 par free mais vous ne réplique est ce
parce que son coin porte caisse non mais
j'aurai des planches aux lieux saints
d'importation et d'exportation
et ben moi j'ai une meilleure affaire
vous proposez vous écoute vous gardez
vos planches pour faire des caisses
alors là j'ai une proposition à vous
faire avec les planches qui moi je
refais les caisses j'achète beaucoup il
me reste des plongeurs fait des caisses
qui dit qu'est ce qui coince vous
rachète vos conneries mois des plongeurs
fait lesquels je vous achète beaucoup un
genre fait des cats et ainsi de suite
voilà mais quand on aura plus de caisses
avant changera de quoi demander la cades
[Musique]